[Music]
you made a surprise appearance people
didn't expect to see you but
WrestleMania 32 yeah I was just a son in
doubt they it was it was fun because I
guess they said there was a scenario
where the rock was in trouble right and
then you come to the rescue and it
people lost their minds they did because
no excited I don't like me but it was a
nice pleasant surprise look you like
that you get you the crowds you like it
when a crowd turns on you well I just
like it when they're excited I'm you
know you're doing sure we got a live
audience who's excited people out there
it's fun right and when they're like
this it's not there's a difference you
like it you just want noise see I if
they were just booing me I wouldn't be
happy but you I'd love it yeah it would
fit my inner expectation of myself but
you you actually with the crowd is
chanting you know John Cena sucks you
know they sing it's actually quite
liberating and you know some people take
it as a negative but I'd like to think
it's the people's way of showing me
admiration it's it's very easy would you
like me to teach you how to do it can we
sing a song as a group can we get this
done here okay so you saw the internet
memes and the trumpets come on it goes
bad so all they do is replace the
trumpets with lyrics they go john cena
sucks we glue your nose is a catchy tune
you ready one two three
John Cena John Cena see you makes you
feel good right
[Applause]
soon to know what to do yeah I want to I
want to hire a gospel choir to do it
yeah oh yeah I'd be amazing for that
except if that's not your ringtone
you're crazy yeah John Cena sucks I got
it all of you are gonna go home tonight
he's on to something
you